get it
good morning today is this birthday and
also the day record for my hitting on
Japan birthday girl doesn't want to wake
up our rooms a mess cuz we're fixing the
pack
and I bought her flowers today if wake
up I guess the worst thing about having
a birthday around the time this year is
fact that you're also battling out
holiday season and so every year around
this time
j/k takes a company trip and so test
birthday always happens to land exactly
on the day or within two or three days
of us leaving or arriving somewhere else
and so her birthday is always kind of it
gets lost in the mix of things in terms
of holiday travels and and events and
stuff like that
so like especially like today it still
has to work she has a lot of uploading
to do for taking news several hundred to
do still a lot of stuff we have to do
before the big trip so I'm trying my
best to make her birthday worthwhile
today um dinner tonight
with the rest of JK family there she is
these are beautiful eyes of yours doodoo
stain on your blanket all right know if
that's a duteous name of that Saints
been there forever
now you're covering it up that's why
all right I'm finally up and out of bed
and yay today's my birthday so right now
we're unpacking things from my car that
we've been buying and you know we have
like the luggage here we bought some new
luggages some mine since Casey I'm
excited about them because it's in my
favorite color so I have two favorite
colors teal and burgundy if you guys
haven't noticed and it's also the art
channel colors sort of unintentionally
because Casey's favorite colors red so
our logo is supposed to be more on the
red side but it turned out to be a
little pinkish but anyways yeah here's
Casey without stuff
Roka oh my goodness
yeah yeah I got this new lip color
yesterday I don't know
what are you guys think does it match
yeah hey guys so I've been very very bad
today I haven't been vlogging because
I've been so busy and I haven't been
able to bring you guys along with me but
I'm here at a Joe's place so because
I've been so busy I've just been busy
oh there's Maddy what's going on Maddy
what's going on we don't like the camera
you're barking at the camera
you cute girl you a cute girl Wow
smoothies doggy Sophie come here mama so
good schulte you should just keep on me
okay Sophie oh girl you smell like fish
ah you girls are too crazy right okay it
does not match for picking up Isaac I
think I'm a bit huh I look I told them
you didn't give me a birthday hug or
kiss feels like oh sorry mom let me give
you a good again for their birthday
everything it was uploading a whole
bunch of videos before I love hey guys
so now we're in the car with Isaac and
Briana and can
actually driving me to my birthday
dinner cuz you're her chauffeurs yeah
yeah I've been up all day today I told
you guys how busy I've been and I have
so many uploads to do so I left my
laptop at their house uploading so I'll
be coming back tonight and I really
don't think that I'm gonna be getting
any sleep tonight because I still have
impact oh yeah and I still I need an
organized egg so not only do I add the
time for myself but I need a pack for
Isaac and I nee make sure that my big
baby Casey has everything that he needs
so yeah tonight I don't I will be
sleeping yeah I'll have ten hours plus
to sleep on the plane
we got here before Casey to attend a
funny cuz like carpools can't agree
we're here give you your present oh I
got excited
what
she gave me a present in the same box
for tonight
journey
if needs to go back to bark
but at the same time you can wear out of
the gym
today we are at the airport and we are
going to Tokyo yes I delete for me
personally I finally can breathe now
that we're at the airport I have my
boarding pass and everything - before
getting the boarding pass in my head
there's so many stressful things going
on around like Isaac school and like
I've expose for it and then gathering
everybody and it's just it's been so
hectic and thank God I had Julia to help
me she helped me plan a lot of it but
yeah so pretty much now that we're here
I'm like I feel like this huge weight
lifted off my shoulders I could finally
be excited for Japan Oh for this morning
I've done what happened this morning
this morning David slept in we kept
calling him over and blowing up his
phone we're about to miss the shuttle
but it's okay
the last time I'm going to get in [ __ ]
and I forgive you know what I was too
busy trying to make your birthday gift I
couldn't bring it because you rushed me
out so I mean I guess it's coda whatever
you have to wait another two weeks for
what happens outside you might wake that
better be true
everyone's getting food now everyone's
trying to get something
what do you know yeah i order breakfast
why would you spend that much at the
airport I was hungry I just ordered a
lot of protein and then I got [ __ ]
over yes you're gonna run out of
spending money in Japan
she's just compared for me honest
choosing food at the airport everyone
was getting sandwiches or burgers I'm
not going to do that because ever since
dating tip all she eats a sandwich is
for burgers don't take a break from that
and I'm gonna pick the wall line that's
the longest yeah when I'm all sleeping
any of your longest lines to the
trillions I mean is good that means all
these other places going through a
questionable questionable yes I'm gonna
get pan Express actually used to work at
Panda Express for like two years and I
hated pen Express for the longest time
but I think I've taken like a ten year
break from Panda Express so join me yes
I'm not the only one
see one is orange chicken c3 is kung pao
chicken b1 is beef and broccoli r2 is
rice white rice
would you consider Panda Express as real
Chinese food
I wouldn't opportunity and expresses
feel Chinese why not if you like real
tiger before isn't that movie but I true
really like heading suspect it looks
like we keep our chicken it's very
crunchy sweetness with their just like a
lot of it's very savory alright so I
feel like it tastes great
I agree everybody love their horse [ __ ]
and I don't consider that we old Chinese
me at all but I still really love that
word chicken you consider been expressed
Chinese food I would say yes and no no
because you're not really gonna find
things updates might shout actual
Chinese restaurant but also yes because
unlike Taco Bell in Tripoli we just
started by a white guy and explicit
action home by Chinese guy there is some
sort of I guess authenticity there it's
kind of like when you art when there is
no Chinese food around it kind of does
do the cheek a little bit but then if
it's like next
Caffe than it like meeting the world's
most expensive tiniest and fun Chinese
one see that's why you shouldn't Chinese
Chris honey that's 10 bucks 20 that's 20
bucks
this is ten bucks that and water is 18
bucks I got this and I got these
shooting on a pan Express you're
laughing at me when I say panic breath
but I tell you that I care about Panda
like Oh cute this is it pinky neither
smart fun today
big burrito yes we equate big lots of
food for lots of money $37 sorry 24 week
actor and I got a beard for 24 bucks
really well agree no a burrito please I
didn't do the math either I mean either
I just say [ __ ] it everybody all day
vacation mode equal to [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
on the company in some business huh it's
to the three ground one way oh that's no
[ __ ] okay
okay
wait isn't everything now who you
excited yes
it's such a huge airplane haul make it
all big this airplane in come on move it
oh sure they do Oh sweetie marry her
everything
nothing Oh Star Wars hello maybe going
up when when Michael is eating a
sandwich warhead this it touches bread
and squeeze the bread just to make sure
just see if it would taste good now he
wants to squeeze the Star Wars toward
justice evil
where
yo where we first Japanese letters oh
you miss all of them Japanese letters
welcome to Japan
do you know about me a red bean and
strawberry mochi
what's our home for the next 10 days you
Penghu Japan home
where are we as a window pane in our new
house let me tour Isaac where we going
door huh and then we we know how to take
off your shoes again welcome thank you
and where did we put our shoes over here
hmm
this door does not open its we're not
going to go in there yes this is the
light there's cool entrance like where
we came in
hey guys what's up dude you gotta check
out this is a bathroom by the back and
this is the jacuzzi - choosing that cool
and then this one do not touch wash and
was that over there thanks to the sink
nice bathroom oh that is a fancy toilet
have you ever seen a toilet like this
before no where you give it a go when
you later alright know what
yeah where's all the livings happening
huh look at the microwave is how are you
but I know it's like sighs I think Ron
has played out what's next whoo this is
nice fancy is the other one huh yep
the shoulder here more stairs yep ever
been in the house it has three stories
three levels this is Josh Josh's and
shine swim yeah Angie ah their place on
here is Barton children my gosh awesome
dinner on our first night we're gonna
take turns eating
I've never seen parcei thank you so much
so politely Oh running a souvenir
oh thank you thank you
holy crap so nice
hey bar do feel more compelled to be
compelled to be more polite here yeah
because I've never said no he thinks
everyone's acting all different here but
in Taiwan though we Valentine want to
though you do yeah so it's like some
little kind of a little bit used to it
no I got rich long bouts all the time
why people like when you humble yourself
it's like you lower yourself so like say
like thanks but it's not in the cultures
family no oh yes like I tried to go off
your mama like Aviva dude isn't a sign
of respect
seems I'm trying to finish the night off
with one last meal I think what's up but
we have a hard time trying to find this
place because things are closed okay you
just be a little get in there timing
where the point was growing up in
gardena you can't help us now so we're
rolling 12 deep and we fill up this
entire restaurant because this is hit I
didn't have very high squad goals
aspirations grown up but I have to say
squad goals are suck right now this is
going to be your first experience a real
deal ramen shop in Japan excited yeah
I'm not even a big like little girl it's
really really don't like that only
getting full up just a bossy person but
even though this is ramen I know you're
excited cuz I want to try those
authentic Japanese ramen so all you do
not ramen
everybody slurping super loud if I lean
over and it's like hey I just while
you're interested it's okay for you to
slurping ahh rude you look really
carefully
bring a little too hard it was like that
was the life